polls show that Americans values are
shifting generationally president Trump
revs up the trade war with China and Joe
Biden still isn't sure where he is I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
we've a lot to get to today and we will
get to all of it hope you had a
wonderful weekend but first have you
noticed that the economy seems to be
sort of up and down have you noticed
that the stock market is up and down
people seem to be uncertain about the
future well now might be a pretty good
time for you to diversify considering
that Germany's about to enter recession
if it has not already done so China is
slowing down that's going to have
ramifications for the rest of the global
economy even if the fundamentals in the
United States are solid this is one of
the reasons why you should be pursuing
gold as part of your portfolio precious
metals should be a part of your profile
in the whole portfolio but at least part
that versification means insulating
yourself against the vicissitudes of the
market it means that the government
can't just inflate you out of your
savings it's a hedge against inflation a
hedge against uncertainty the company I
trust with precious metal purchases is
Birch gold group look back historically
when the bottom falls out of everything
else Gold does tend to safeguard savings
which is why the prices have been rising
with the uncertainty Birch gold group
has thousands of satisfied customers
countless five-star reviews an A+ rating
with the Better Business Bureau contact
Birch gold group right now get a free
information kit on physical precious
metals see if diversifying into gold and
silver makes sense for you this
comprehensive 16 page kit reveals how
gold and silver can protect your savings
to get that no-cost no-obligation kit
text Ben - 47 47 47 again that has been
in my name - 47 47 47 get in touch with
my friends over at Birch gold group and
find out what you can do to safeguard
your savings okay so we have a lot to
get to today we will get to President
Trump and the trade war with China
whether it is justified or unjustified
in just a few minutes first however
there's a poll that is making an awful
lot of waves as a poll from the Wall
Street Journal and NBC News and what it
shows is that Americans views about
politics and life generally are changing
pretty radically and that is not a
particularly surprise generation Z
Millennials these are kids who have
grown up in a morally relativistic
universe in which they are told that the
only value is acceptance and tolerance
except for acceptance and tolerance of
those who think differently those people
need to be ostracized those people need
to be outed those people need
to be shamed everything else is good to
go
not only that these are kids who have
been taught that in the two-sided sort
of war over America's narrative one side
that says America was founded in eternal
truths and goodness and was and was
taken away from by the fact that it was
concurrently found at a time in which
slavery was reprehensibly present on the
American continent and was part of the
founding bargain that when when all of
this happened that the good side of
America is the side that is worth
focusing on because the story of America
has a story of us perfecting our own
fulfillment of eternal values right
that's a story that it was told by
everybody from Abraham Lincoln to
Frederick Douglass to Martin Luther King
jr. and there's the other side of the
American story
and that side is America was rooted as
the 16:19 projects as in racism and
sexism and bigotry and homophobia all of
our institutions are suffused by it all
of our institutions are replete with it
and thus these are inextricably
intertwined and the institutions have to
be torn down these are the two visions
of American history well if you're a
millennial or if you are a or if you're
a gens ear the chances are that you have
heard more from your public schooling
and from the media world about the
second narrative than you have about the
first narrative the first narrative is
considered parochial and insular that
first narrative is considered brazen and
wrong it's the second narrative that
shows your humility see the hilarious
thing about the second narrative is that
supposedly it shows your humility as an
American when in reality it shows your
arrogance as a modern person because yes
it is more humble to talk about
America's flaws in the context of
America's history but it is also a lot
more arrogant for you to sit around
saying that you're so much better than
people who live 200 years ago as though
you would be implementing your values
today 200 years ago were you only living
then the fact is you wouldn't be you'd
have grown up in an entirely different
circumstance but we live in a generation
that believes that the world the ends
spinning with their birth and this has
really been true since the baby boomers
who may have wrecked the country and
then won't leave us alone as it turns as
it turns out the baby boomer spends an
awful lot of time talking about how they
transformed the world they seemed not to
recognize how they ripped away a lot of
fundamental values that undergirded
the American bargain in the first place
hey so anyway here are the results of
the new poll it's a new poll conducted
by The Wall Street Journal and NBC
nearly 80% of people aged 55 to 91 said
being patriotic is important to them
only 42 percent of Millennials and Gen
zere's those aged 18 to 38 that's my age
group said the same that's a shocking
drop-off so about half the number of
Millennials and Gen Z errs as the number
of people who are baby boomers and above
think that being patriotic is important
but that's not even talking about
nationalism right there's this this rich
debate on the right about the
differences between patriotism and
nationalism is America a country founded
on a Creed or as America a country
founded on a culture and ties of blood
and ties of history and what exactly
makes America America that's what that's
a rich and interesting debate on the one
side you have people like David French
on the other side you have people like
rich Lowry over at National Review of
Yoram hezonia on the nationalistic side
and you have Jonah Goldberg on the
patriotic side and there's agreement and
disagreement among them that's an
interesting and important debate
philosophically but all of them would
agree that patriotism is important and
even Democrats used to agree that
patriotism was important that an
inherent pride in country was an
important thing because America is a
uniquely wonderful place that has
brought about uniquely wonderful things
namely freedom and prosperity to
billions the globe over that's an
incredible thing
America is the freest most prosperous
country in the history of the world most
powerful country in the history of the
world it ain't closed by the way America
is so much more powerful than the
British Empire or the Roman Empire it
would boggle the mind and that's not
just because of technological advances
that's because of the power of the
American economy which is embedded in
all of the other economies globally as
America rises the rest of the world
Rises as America sinks the rest of the
world sinks being patriotic is an
important part of being American because
there is a lot of us to be proud of but
the Millennials and trans ears have been
taught that they can actually feel
better about themselves by disdaining
patriotism see they're not American
citizens they're world citizens they're
global citizens there's only one problem
with that there's really no such thing
as a global value it really is not
unless you're talking about religious
values which as it turns out Millennials
and Gen zere's also reject so what kind
of global values are you talking about
that you hold in common with the
government of China or with the
government of Iran
what kind of global values are you
talking about that subsume American
values under the
Brook what exactly are you talking about
Americans should be patriotic we should
be America is something to be proud of
right you're lucky that you were born
here if you were born here if you
immigrated here you know how lucky you
are to be here right the vast majority
of us have ancestors who did immigrated
here and knew how lucky they were to be
here in the first place how you could
live in this country and not believe
that being patriotic is important is
mind boggling but that is a testament to
the horrors of the American public
school system in our university system
in our media all of whom have
simultaneously declared that patriotism
is passe that to be patriotic is to
sneer at other countries now that's not
what we're talking about
I can I can freely acknowledge the
wonders inherent in Chinese culture or
British culture or Italian culture while
recognizing that America is something
unique America is something incredible
America is something to be proud of I
mean this is this is a massive
generation gap and it's gonna have a
significant impact because if you do not
feel pride in being an American well
then what exactly is the culture that
you are seeking to preserve what are the
ideas that you are seeking to preserve
what makes America well what makes our
ideas and philosophy and values better
than anyplace else and if they're not
better than anyplace else well then why
should we seek to preserve them why not
just have open borders why not just take
the advice of other countries on matters
related to how domestic policy is done
what exactly are the values we should
all be defending now normally when
people say patriotism in the United
States it doesn't just mean that they're
proud of the flag or they're proud of
the American military it means they're
proud of our traditions of free speech
our right to bear arms the Constitution
of the United States which is a sort of
secular holy document to the citizens of
the United States the Declaration of
Independence these are our twin founding
documents the Declaration and the
Constitution and respects for those
founding documents belief in the rights
that they lay forth belief in the system
of government that they talk about
that's inherent to patriotism but if you
are not patriotic about those things
what in there is worth upholding maybe
you want to substitute a European
version of Rights maybe you want to
substitute a European version of hate
speech
maybe you want to imitate other
countries and how they deal with their
problems and this is what we are seeing
more and more in the United States is
this belief that America is
anachronistic not in a good way because
we are at
exceptional in a bad way and this is why
you see so many folks on the political
left talking about America is the only
country on earth developed country that
doesn't have a universal health care
system first of all we have something
that sort of approaches a universal
health care system is why we have
Medicaid it's why we have Medicare it's
why we also have laws on the books that
require emergency room treatment for
people who show up at a hospital we do
have something that resembles it it may
be too expensive it may be a bad mix of
private and public but obviously the
reason that people talk about this on
the left America as anachronism is
because they believe that America should
be more like other countries where as
true patriots believe that more
countries should be more like America
that the world would be a better place
if countries were more like America you
hear this with regard to gun control all
the time
why is America the only developed
country that allows people don't why is
America the most powerful economy on
earth why is America the freest country
on earth why is it that you can come to
America and hope to become Bill Gates
whereas you go to Europe and you hope to
be on a welfare check the rest of your
life why is it that America is wonderful
you're looking at America and seeing
only the downsides is so myopic it's
bound to make you insane but it's not
just as it turns out patriotism that is
on the downswing 30 percent of
Millennials and generations II said
religion is important compared to over
75 percent of baby boomers just over
thirty percent of Millennials and
Generation Z said it was important to
even have children hey these are these
were the values that bound us together
right pride in America and where you
lived in the values that made America
great okay and and belief in religion
belief that religion was important that
doesn't mean we all have to agree and
our particular religious precepts we
disagree here at the Daily wire offices
all the time I'd say the leadership team
here at the Daily wire offices has
significant religious disagreements my
business partner is a lay pastor I'm an
Orthodox Jew yeah we've talked about
Jesus before it doesn't mean that what
it means is that understanding the
religious basis of a moral life in the
United States is actually quite
important because as John Adams said the
Constitution was made only for a moral
and religious people it is very
difficult to sustain a system of rights
when you don't trust your neighbor what
allows you to trust your neighbor
knowing that your neighbor goes to
church really knowing their neighbor
goes to synagogue doesn't mean there
aren't great atheists there are their
wonderful moral atheists I'm friends
with many of them made some of the top
atheist in the country I'm friends with
them I'm friends with Sam Harris that's
fine that's not the argument that I'm
making the argument that I'm making is
that
culture of trust requires you to have
common values and atheism does not
necessarily push a set of common values
whereas if you're going to church with
somebody that certainly is a social
social institution that does generate
common values if you lose these social
institutions you're not spending time
with neighbors you don't know the people
you live next to you don't know the
people in your community there's no
social safety net that is going to lead
to the rise of a massive government that
is supposed to fill the gap where the
social institutions have failed this is
why you've seen Millennials and
Generation Z
talking more and more about reliance on
the government as opposed to reliance on
local community and very often when you
talk to younger people and you say you
know your community will help pick you
up they look at you cross-eyed they say
what community and they're not wrong as
a religion has decreased in the United
States there's a greater call for the
involvement of the collective that
collective used to be present in places
like churches and synagogues it is no
longer present particularly among young
people who have disdains religion
because they feel that it's too
restrictive with regards to their lives
and then they've created their own new
religion and that religion is leftism a
religion that has sinners but no Saints
a religion that has no forgiveness a
religion that is as brutal as any
religion in history I mean over the
course of the 20th century leftism sure
killed a few hundred million people but
the fact is that thirty percent of
Millennials and generations eza religion
is important to them so we don't ever
legend in common and more anymore when a
patriotism in common anymore so you'd
say ok well at least we have a belief in
the future right at least we want to
make the country better for our kids
except that this poll shows only 30% of
Millennials in Generation Z say it's
even important to have children and this
makes perfect sense it does as a choral
ordering - I don't care about patriotism
and I don't care about religion the
question becomes why would you think
it's important to have children why like
well what makes it what makes it
important and valuable for you to
progenitor generation of kids we'll talk
about this in just one second first
let's talk about your sleep quality so
polls like this may make you uneasy they
make it difficult for you to sleep at
night but good news we have a solution
that is helix sleep mattresses they're
so good that I got one for my sister and
her husband upon the occasion of their
wedding it really is a fantastic
mattress helix sleep has a quiz it takes
two minutes to complete it matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect man
for you no matter how you sleep on your
side on your back hot sleeper whatever
it is helix can make what your body
needs just go to helix sleep calm slash
been take there two minutes leap quiz
they will match you to a customized
mattress it will give you the best sleep
of your life when you're on the when I'm
on the road I really do not sleep well
specifically because I missed my helix
sleep mattress when I come home I'm so
relieved because I know that the
mattress is going to be tailored to me
as it was my wife and I took the
two-minute sleep quiz the mattress
arrived in the mail
you simply unpack it and inflates in
front of you pop it on bed frame you're
good to go right now
helix is offering up to 125 bucks off
all mattress orders for our listeners
and guess what you can try it out for
100 nights risk-free they'll even pick
it up for you if you don't love it but
you will leave got a 10 year warranty as
well so I mean you really have nothing
to lose get up to 125 bucks off at helix
sleep comm / Ben that's helix sleep comm
/ Ben for up to 125 bucks off your
mattress order helix sleep calm / Ben so
as I say the final pull difference here
is that 30 percent of Millennials and
Generation Z say it's important to have
kids well why would they say it's
important to have kids and really what
makes it important have children so I
know why I have children I have children
not because it is quote unquote
enriching enriching to me although I
think it has changed my life in massive
incredible ways as I say repeatedly I
think that having children makes you a
better person because the more
responsibility you take on in life the
better a person you become as I've said
a thousand times on this show having
children also broadens your vision of
the world as I've said when you're
single your spectrum of happiness to
sadness goes from maybe like a 10 to a
zero and then when you get married your
spectrum of happiness goes from like a
20 to a negative 20 because your
spouse's pain is also your pain in your
spouses happiness is also your happiness
and then you have kids and the upper
limit goes way in the bottom one that
goes away and the worst moments of your
life are things happening with your kids
in the best moments of your life are
also things happening with their kids
all of that is a good self-interested
case for having children but let's be
real about this having having kids is
tough accepting more responsibility is
tough okay they they cost a lot of money
then a pain in the butt it takes 18
years to raise them and then they may
still be a work they may be horrible you
have no control over them after they hit
18 right having kids is a burden which
is why religion suggested that it was in
that you must as a matter of morality
progenitor
have more
it was a matter of morality you were put
on earth to have more kids and to raise
them properly this is one of your
missions on the planet this is also
bound up in the patriotic mission of
having good kids who are going to enact
American morality and guarantee a future
for the greatest country in the history
of the world and the philosophy of that
country if you don't have any higher
values in other words there really is
not a lot of reason to have kids in fact
what polls show is that a lot of couples
you don't have kids are pretty happy why
well because hell I mean I can
understand why I've had kids I've not
had kids I understand who'd be fun to go
out with my wife every night it'd be
great not to have to spend hundreds of
thousands of dollars on children I get
it when you live it used to be that
people and it still is people in poorer
countries have lots of kids why because
those kids are units of labour right so
I'm really a religious thing it's you
need somebody to work the farm and take
care of you when you get old in the
United States well I got a fake Social
Security program to take care of you
when you get old and kids don't take
care anyway they're lazy they're up in
their room playing video games that you
bought for them until they can leave the
house and then make fun of you right so
why would you in a hedonistic society
why have kids
okay so you've taken away commonality of
values when it comes to a country you've
taken away a commonality of values when
it comes to God and a common vision
you've taken away a commonality of
values when it comes to guarantees of
the future because if nobody's having
babies then what exactly are we waiting
for just blow out the debt right now and
you don't have to worry about the next
generation they're not going to exist
anyway surely the entire house of cards
is going to cave in on itself and hell
maybe the solution is that you bring in
lots and lots of new immigrants and you
don't really worry whether they share
your values because after all patriotism
doesn't matter and they come in and then
they are going to work hard I mean first
of all there is something deeply cynical
about suggesting that immigrants are
supposed to come in and pay the bills
for you that's a really messed up on a
moral level yeah well I want some new
immigrant who's seeking a freer life to
come pay my Social Security that's
absurdity on the highest level but with
all of that said what we are watching
right now is a dramatic decrease in all
the valleys that used to unify the
country so patriotism declined massively
belief in God declining massively having
children declining massively
self-fulfillment actually visit I love
this so the value of self-fulfillment
this is where young people are
succeeding okay so when it comes to
sulfa
element and belief in in making yourself
feel better
right there the Millennials and Gen Z
really have it on the mark right there
nearly 80% of Millennials and Gen Z's
say that it is very important to be self
fulfilled what about sixty percent of
older people say it's important to be
self fulfilled so we are now living in
the fully subjectivist hedonistic silly
ideology of self fulfillment rather than
any vision of morality or objective
decency or anything like that it what's
amazing about this is this doesn't
suggest by the way the boomers in the
Silent Generation are actually
intolerant in fact in terms of tolerance
for others the boomers and the
Millennials actually have basically the
same value set and the same thing is
true when it comes to financial security
when it comes to hard work it's very
close and so when it comes to I want to
work hard or I want financial security
or I want to be tolerance of other
people the generations are fairly close
the gaps emerged when it comes to higher
values when it comes to higher values
older people have it right and younger
people have it wrong it is indeed that
simple not shockingly and the vast gaps
are indeed partisan over 80% of
Republicans say patriotism is important
compared to just over 40 percent of
Democrats part of this by the way has to
do with who's the president there have
been polls that show that Democratic
feelings about patriotism vary with the
presidents when Obama was president
Democrats were super patriotic but
Republicans by the way didn't become
unpatriotic like 70% of Republicans felt
they were patriotic then Trump became
president and that jumped about 5 to 10
points for Republicans and it dropped
off like 40 for Democrats if your
patriotic based on who the president is
you're doing patriotism wrong belief in
God about 70% of Republicans say it's
important only 40% of Democrats to under
60% of Republicans say it's important to
have kids which is a shocking number
under 40% of Democrats say it's
important to have kids many more
Republicans than Democrats believe in
hard work when it comes to tolerance for
others about 70 percent of Republicans
say that that is a high value as opposed
to nearly a hundred percent of Democrats
because obviously these are the values
of difference and self fulfillment
Democrats outrank Republicans there as
well so the the emerging generation just
does not have the same values well what
does this say about our politics it says
our politics are about to get a lot
uglier because the fact is that
you know Clausewitz the the famous
military strategic strategist he used to
suggest that war is simply politics by
other means meaning that you are ten
things you get something done you can't
get it done politically so you go to war
well the problem is when you don't share
values with the people you live with
what ends up happening is that is that
politics tends to be war by other means
meaning the only thing stopping war is
the fact that we're drawing at each
other right now that may be better than
war I mean as Winston Churchill famously
said draw draw is better than war war
that's true it's true to talk and it is
war on one another but the line is
getting very thin and if you really
believe that the values that distinguish
you from your neighbor are worth going
to war over and that the thin veneer of
civilization is all that keeps us from
being at each other's throats that's not
much of a veneer you need a
revivification of American values you
need a belief in patriotism you need to
re-educate your kids about what being
American means and yes with all the ugly
parts and yes with the ugly history but
we have decided that we can't even face
up to a narrative that allows America to
be the good guy in the world which by
the way America is the good guy in the
world America is good and we're not
teaching young people anything I mean
our educational system is such an
enormous failure parents are failing
their kids in teaching their kids
there's another poll out today that
shows that young Americans are warming
to socialism because they don't know
what the hell it is according to the
according to ABC News there there's a
new Pew Research Center poll and it says
that more than half of Americans reject
socialism in a recent Gallup poll 43%
surveyed said some version of it would
be good for the country that sentiment
was held by 58% of respondents aged 18
to 34 compared with just 36 percent of
those 55 and older why because they
don't know what socialism is they really
don't know how to define it these polls
always ask can you define socialism and
then they just define it the Bernie
Sanders way it means being nice to each
other it means sharing car money a
little bit no that's that's not what
socialism means guys means the
nationalization of the means of
production and then use of that
nationalization to cram down whatever
distribution of wealth you find fair
usually with a few people at the top to
get rich off of it what we are watching
right now is a complete failure of
education a complete collapse in the
inculcation of American values and I
think part of this had to do with the
fall of the Soviet Union I do not think
that it is a coup
the generation born during and after the
fall of the Soviet Union is abandoning
core American values and embracing
socialism part of that is because
there's no existential threat from a
Soviet Union type state an evil empire
that is threatening nuclear annihilation
against the United States while
simultaneously keeping its people in
poverty and poisoning them with nuclear
fallout Isla Chernobyl right it's a lot
easier to defend your own system in
opposition to another system than to
defend your own system in opposition to
a vacuum it's it's it's very difficult
to justify every action you take in a
vacuum because after all we all sin the
United States us in United States has
some grave awful sins on its record but
when you face them up to the Soviet
Union it's pretty obvious who the good
guy is and who the bad guys well the
Soviet Union Falls and suddenly the
United States is asked to justify its
own its own system against nothing
against nothing or against dreams
against utopian dreams of the left well
it turns out that's pretty difficult to
do because the other side meaning people
who don't like the American system don't
have to defend anything they can just
club they can just they can just beat
down people and this sort of the same
attitude when it comes to the Middle
East where you ignore Israel's opponents
and you just focus in on Israel and say
ah well look at all these bad things
Israel's doing
I'm sure Israel does bad things in fact
I've criticized Israel for doing some
bad things but you can't look at them in
a vacuum you can't look at the United
States or capitalism or free markets in
a vacuum if you do you're doing it wrong
but this is what we have taught our kids
to do and again they believe that
America is bad mainly because they've
never lived anywhere else they've ever
seen the apathy the opposition to the
United States and that is dis unifying
the country all of which brings us to
president Trump's trade war with the
Chinese now I think that there is a
solid case to be made for as Niall
Ferguson has suggested the historian
Niall Ferguson has suggested that we
need a cold war 2.0 that China is
actually incredibly dangerous and I
think that this is actually true I think
that China is incredibly dangerous we
just haven't been talking about it
because since the end of the Cold War we
haven't wanted to and we haven't wanted
to acknowledge the fact the China's
massive growth which has in fact
enriched the United States free trade
tends to enrich both sides because these
are mutually beneficial exchanges but
that bringing China
the so-called family of Nations was
bringing a fox into the chicken coop
that China actually is a malevolent
force on the world stage and this is not
just because President Trump is mad a
China this goes back a lot further than
that and the Chinese strategy since Mao
has been to see the United States as its
opponents and take measures against the
United States is particularly true under
the current dictator of China Xi Jinping
the former Deng guest whose call after
Deng who is the the president / prime
minister he was the leader of the
Chinese Communist Party for years his
goal was to slowly grow Chinese power
without offending the West too much
well Xi Jinping is now making incredibly
aggressive moves around the world in
direct opposition to America's interest
and saying to people that it's in direct
opposition to the United States there
are a couple of initiatives that are
worth knowing about that that ji Jinping
is involved in first of all they
continue to build up of the military the
continued testing of treaty violating
weaponry bill Gertz has a great new book
out about the threat that china
constitutes on the world stage but there
are a couple of initiatives that folks
really need to focus in on this is where
as I've been saying I think that
President Trump if he wants a trade war
with the Chinese if he is ready to bring
America face to face with the specter of
Chinese communism which is aggressive
and which does need to be curbed then
the president owes it to the American
people to make a speech in which he lays
out exactly what China has been doing
and why they're a malevolent force
because the fact is for a lot of years
there's been a lot of people saying that
China's fine trend is our friend we're
getting along fine with them they're
good you know and if they grow
economically good that means fewer
people in poverty look we all want fewer
people in poverty but we don't want that
enriching a regime that is then once
keep a billion and a half people under
the Communist heel while building up a
massive land army as well as taking over
shipping lanes in the South China Sea in
just a second I'm gonna lay forth the
actual threat of China on the world
stage there are several areas in which
China is becoming an increasing threat
and in many ways more of a threat than
the Soviet Union even was the Soviet
Union was an overt threat because of
their nuclear tipped missiles pointed
right at the United States and because
of their threats to take over territory
in Eastern Europe for example they'd
already taken over Eastern Europe but to
move into Western Europe or to roll on
into
areas like Afghanistan all of that was
deeply threatening but the fact is that
Russia was a second-rate economy China
is moving quickly into the ranks of a
first-rate economy and they are doing so
at the same time that they are building
up their military and making the same
sort of territorial overtures to regimes
around the world to place them in
opposition to America's interests we'll
get to that in just one second first and
we're talking about wake-up calls
well maybe every morning you need a
wake-up call I do that's why I have
black rifle coffee black rifle coffee I
mean this is strong stuff okay this is
not for the weak-minded black rifle
coffee is so I only can take their light
roast I'll be honest with you I'm not
man enough to take the dark roast from
black rifle coffee black rifle coffee is
awesome there's nothing quite like black
rifle coffee when it comes to giving you
a kick in the pants with tons of
different rows to choose from black
rifle ships the best rows to order
coffee directly to your door a portion
of all of black rifles profits go to
supporting veteran law enforcement fire
and first responder causes when you
drink black rifle coffee not only do you
become more masculine but you're
supporting the company that serves
coffee and culture to people who truly
love America I know the dudes who run
black rifle coffee they are awesome guys
there are veterans these are people have
served the country and now they're
serving the country coffee which is
pretty awesome if you've been on the
fence about joining the black rifle
coffee club there is no better time than
now help them reach their goal of
hitting a hundred thousand club members
by the end of this month and get access
to discounts and offers not available to
other customers visit black rifle coffee
calm slash Ben get 20% off your first
purchase that's black rifle coffee calm
slash Ben for 20% off your first
/ Ben great coffee great folks go
support than black rifle coffee dot-com
ok so let's talk about the threat of
China so China is involved in something
they like to call the belt and road
initiative The Economist reported on
this back in May of 2017 and they gave a
pretty good summary of it so I'll use
their summary they say over the weekend
Xi Jinping welcomed 28 heads of state
and government to Beijing for a
coming-out party which continues today
to celebrate the belt and Road
initiative his most ambitious foreign
policy launched in 2013 as one belt one
road it involves China underwriting
billions of dollars of infrastructure
investment in countries along the old
Silk Road linking it with Europe the
ambition is immense China is spending
roughly one hundred and fifty billion
dollars a year in the 68
countries that have signed up to the
scheme the summit meeting has attracted
the largest number of foreign
dignitaries since the Olympic Games in
2008 Europe has been ignoring it so what
exactly is the Belton road initiative
the project is the clearest expression
so far according to the Economist a mr.
G's determination to break with Deng
Xiaoping's dictum to hide our
capabilities and bide our time never try
to take the lead the belt and road forum
which was actually called barf is the
second set peace event this year at
which mr. G will lay out China's claim
to global leadership there is also the
World Economic Forum in 2017 the
ultimate aim here is to make Eurasia
dominated by China in economic and
trading rival to rival trading area to
rival the transatlantic one dominated by
the United States is one of the reasons
why President Obama for all the crap he
took for it was actually not doing the
wrong thing with the trans-pacific
partnership there are holes in the
trans-pacific partnership there are
problems with the deal that deal needed
to be opened up so that we could
actually take a look at it but the idea
of creating a trading bloc to shut out
China was actually quite a good one
behind this broad strategic imperative
by a plethora of secondary motivations
and is the number and variety of these
says the economists that prompt
skepticism about the coherence and
practicality of the project by investing
in infrastructure she hopes to find a
more profitable home for China's vast
foreign exchange reserves most of which
are in low interest bearing American
government securities but that's not
really what this is about it ain't about
trying to making money really what they
want is to invest in volatile countries
in Central Asia so that they can expand
their areas of influence by encouraging
more Chinese projects around the South
China Sea the initiative could bolster
China's claims in that area when it belt
and road belt refers to the actual roads
the road refers to sea lanes and the sea
lanes are what China wants to take
control of so this may not be a smart
investment on a monetary level but this
is obviously a foreign policy initiative
that the Chinese are trying to use on
foreign countries they're offering them
all sorts of sweetheart deals in order
so that they can help control their
economy and control their foreign policy
future and direct it against the United
States it's not merely that China is
also pursuing its own 5g strategy so the
United States has a decentralized
approach to 5g the United States is
basically allowed private companies to
take the lead China is not doing that
right China has been sponsoring Huawei
right they are they are using literally
billions of dollars to pump money into
the development of 5g and they're
offering it more and more to developing
countries at discounted prices why
because they also can use Huawei to spy
on the material in those countries and
many countries don't care many countries
are simply taking huawei's technology
because it's cheaper and okay well if
the Chinese have a backdoor to grab data
5g according to CNBC is designed to
bring faster speeds and lower lag times
than previous wireless networks like 4G
and 3G while much has been said about
how the networks will give consumers
faster downloads of videos or games 5g
is perhaps more importantly a potential
game-changer for functions such as
driverless cars or remote surgery that
require a quick reliable internet
connections mobile operators like
Verizon and AT&T have started trying
their own 5g China is taking a
centralized approach they're pumping
money into the technology as a
government initiative US officials say
that Chinese companies like Huawei
should not be allowed to build out the
critical infrastructure such as radio
networking equipment and software that
would enable 5g they warn that Huawei
equipment could create a backdoor for
the Chinese government to spy on
American networks intelligence experts
have been skeptical about Huawei's
assurances that they aren't a security
risk and he's seen the Trump
administration cracked down on Huawei
specifically because of all of this
China has the ability and the desire to
weaponize technologies like 5g not only
that once they have their own 5g network
and all of America's ISPs are expected
to operate off of huawei's 5g network
well then it's gonna be very easy to
control information that is going into
and out of countries at Google as Peter
Thiel's points now Google is already
cutting deals with the Chinese to
restrict the flow of information into
China if they hope to operate in country
well what happens when trying to expand
sits 5g across Africa into Latin America
across Asia and suddenly information
cannot penetrate there when it comes to
information warfare 5g is actually
extraordinarily important so President
Trump wants to talk about infrastructure
building then what we actually should be
talking about if we want a moon project
we should develop be developing an
American 5g network that is cheaper
faster and more reliable than the
Chinese Network and then we should make
that technology available to American
private companies hey China is in fact
interest they're stealing by some
estimates up to five or six hundred
billion dollars American intellectual
property every
single year so yes China is a threat
okay all that wise is the backgrounds
what President Trump is doing with China
and their an ideological threat you have
to understand that China is a communist
country China is a country that wishes
to see a centralized government dominate
every aspect of life
China has rolled out in country a system
of social ranking that allows people to
be barred from certain professions it
allows people to be treated in a certain
way because the government gathers
information about you and then ranks you
at as a citizen if that sounds creepy
and Big Brother that's because it is
creepy and Big Brother hey China has a
million people in gulags basically right
now for the Kremen being Muslim probably
talk about America and the West being
Islamophobic nobody seems to talk about
the the you Gers in China if that's how
it's pronounced or being held a million
of them in internment camps because of
their religion China is an ideological
opponents when I said earlier that
America needs an ideological opponent to
contrast China would be it now would be
a pretty good time for President Trump
to lay that out I'll talk a little bit
more about that in just a second but
first there are a lot of types of car on
the roads and that means it's very
difficult to find all of the car parts
that you actually need for your car when
you just go to a local auto parts store
instead what you need is a thing called
the interwebs and on the interwebs
there's a thing called Rock Auto comm
Rock auto comm is awesome why well first
of all they'll make it easier for you to
find the exact part that you need second
they'll bring it to you at a price that
is gonna be the best on the market
rockauto.com is a family business
serving Auto Parts customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers they've got everything
from engine control modules and brake
parts to tail lamps motor oil even new
carpet whether it's for your classic or
daily driver get everything you need in
a few easy clicks delivered directly to
your door
the rockauto.com catalog is super easy
to navigate quickly see all the parts
available for your vehicle and filter by
brands specifications and prices best of
all prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers
they've got amazing selection reliably
low prices all the parts our car will
ever need so why in the world would you
go to a physical location for auto parts
when you can go to Rock Auto calm head
on over to rockauto.com right now see
all the parts available for your car or
truck right shapiro in there how did you
hear about us box so they know we sent
you again that's Rock Auto comm go check
them out and right Shapiro's in that how
did
you hear about us box so they know that
we sent you it we'll get some more about
China and the burgeoning trade war in
just a second first got a remind you you
need to tune in tomorrow 7 p.m. Eastern
4 p.m. Pacific for our latest episode of
the conversation our host Michael
Knowles I know I can't believe you're
still working here we'll be answering
your questions live on air so make them
good the episode is free to watch on
Facebook and YouTube but only
subscribers can ask the questions
so those subscribe to daily wire get
your questions answered by Michael
tomorrow Tuesday August 27th 7 p.m.
Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific and join the
conversation
also The Daily wire has turned four
years old so thank you guys as a thank
you to our fans who are giving away one
month of our premium monthly
subscription to anyone who uses this
code birthday because it's our boot a
man for all of August as we celebrate
this milestone we are giving away a free
first month for new premium monthly
subscribers again just use the code
birthday time is quickly running out so
come on over and join the fun again use
that promo code birthday and that means
that you will get a special deal and you
should join us
also because let's face it the left
sucks many of them are trying to destroy
this show trying to destroy all of our
other daily wire shows the folks at
Media Matters have a membership why
shouldn't you go check us out right now
daily wire comm for $9.99 a month
ninety-nine bucks a year also gives you
the greatest in beverage vessel the
leftist year's hot or cold tumblr tumblr
as we'd like to call him in fact a giant
version of tumbly showed up at the last
day lee weyer event but if you weren't
graced with his presence you could be
graced with his younger brothers
presents by simply subscribing over at
daily wire comm for $99 a year we really
appreciate it we're the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
so as I say China is in fact a a real
geopolitical rival to the United States
they're trying to run roughshod over
Hong Kong and they're trying to run
roughshod over Taiwan they have they've
already run Russia roughshod over Tibet
they're trying currently to run
roughshod over India okay they are they
are a dangerous powerful force in the
world they have a long-term vision they
don't care if their own citizens have to
suffer if this all would be a pretty
good predicate for the United States
taking some pretty harsh action against
the Chinese now President Trump has
taken this dual tactic one tactic is to
suggest to the American people that
tariffs on trying to benefit the
American economy Falls and the other has
been to suggest that China is a real
threat to the globe on a security level
true now really what he should be doing
is if he's gonna call for Americans to
make a sacrifice he should be making a
speech laying out all this stuff I just
explained to you laying out China's
philosophy laying out the government's
philosophy what they're trying to do why
she just decided that he would make
himself dictator for life what his
actual vision for the world is and that
vision includes a centralized Chinese
dominated government sphere that ranges
all the way from China and across Asia
even down to Africa and Latin America
where they're trying to push into the 5g
Network area they're trying to use their
belton road initiative all across the
world and all of this is incredibly
dangerous and China and Trump could lay
this out he could lay this out and
frankly he should lay this out because
the American people have been lied to by
policymakers on both sides the Bush
administration treated the Chinese of
the kid gloves the Clinton
administration certainly treated the
Chinese with kid gloves they went so far
as to basically allow the transfer of
technology to China that violated
national security precepts and the Obama
administration was incredibly soft on
China except for maybe the TPP well
Trump has not been soft on China but
he's not been clear about why he's not
being soft on China instead he has
suggested that China is screwing us on
trade which in some ways they are I mean
they've cheated on trade but that free
trade is really the problem and that
there's not going to be any blowback
economically if we are to cut off the
Chinese at the knees that obviously is
untrue here's President Trump talking
about China hurting us for 30 years on a
security level this is true it's true
also with regard to intellectual
property theft
it may be true with regard to subsidies
although when another country subsidizes
a particular business sometimes that's
actually good for the United States's
economy
nonetheless the real case against China
is a security case it is not an economic
case arose from making the economic case
however with China and well win it
China's been hurting our country for 30
years with the money they've been taken
out other president should have done
something about it and they should have
done it a long time ago I'm doing it and
I have no choice because we're not gonna
lose close to a trillion dollars a year
to China and China understands that we
have helped rebuild China like nobody
else and they've done a great job and I
don't blame China I blame our presidents
our representatives past administrations
for allowing that to happen it's a
disgrace okay what Trump says there is a
hundred percent true again the fact is
that the United States treated China
with kid gloves because they were trying
to separate off China from the Soviet
Union this is why Nixon opened China
back in the 1970s and since then the
Russians have gone down the USSR has
gone down the tubes but the Chinese
government has become a world threat a
serious international power Trump said
yesterday I could declare a national
emergency if I really wanted to get
American businesses to stop doing
business with China I could just declare
a national emergency I mean he could
that would not be the best way to do it
but the fact is he needs to lay out for
the American public why China is a
threat not just because they're
quote-unquote screwing us on trade but
because they are an international threat
to the international system representing
what socialism actually looks like when
a top-down government controls every
aspect of life here is Trump will have
the right to national
I think when they when they steal and
you take out an intellectual property
theft anywhere from 300 billion to 500
billion dollars a year and when we have
a total loss of almost a trillion
dollars a year for many years to be
going on in many ways it's an emergency
I have no plan right now actually we're
getting along very well with China right
now we're talking I think they want to
make it deal much more than I do
okay again this is where you get the
mixed signal so on the one hand it's
China stealing intellectual property
from us China is an enemy of the United
States on the other hand it's I want to
kind of deal with them maybe we'll kind
of deal with them maybe it'll be all
better we need some sort of cohesive if
Trump wants leverage against the Chinese
he has to motivate the American people
to be behind him in his adversarial
action against the Chinese because the
media obviously are gonna play this game
whether they suggest that Trump should
just cut a deal with the Chinese and
that it's Trump's fault the economy is
sinking and that's what's going on right
now because there is a third player in
US versus China and that is public
perception American public perception
she does not have to worry about that
she can simply kill anybody doesn't like
that granny needs a communist dictator
can at least imprison them a ruin their
lives
yeah but Trump has to worry about public
opinion so if you want to negotiate with
the Chinese and you want to present a
strong face to the Chinese you have to
make the American people aware of what
it is the Chinese are doing and it can't
simply be offhanded remarks about
intellectual property theft that's
that's too much for people it's or too
little rather you actually have to lay
out what China's ambitions are on the
world stage President Trump again has
been sending these mixing NAL's and I
think that Trump is the only president
in my lifetime who's actually been
taking the proper adversarial view of
China but he's not laid forth exactly
why he is doing that and that's what I'm
calling on me to do I think President
Trump can make a very strong stand here
against the Chinese government and
explain to the American people why he is
doing what he is doing he started to do
this last Friday
all right last Friday he tweeted out a
bunch of stuff about China he said he
started off by saying by ripping into
the Fed suggesting that this is all the
feds fault he said the Fed did nothing
he said that that he will work
brilliantly with with the Fed in order
to in order to make the United States
economy better etcetera etc etc but then
he got to his real target of ire and
this Chinese as our country has lost
stupidly true
millions of dollars with China over many
years they've stolen our intellectual
property at the rate of hundreds of
billions of dollars a year and want to
continue I won't let that happen
we don't need China and frankly would be
far better off without them the vast
amounts of money made and stolen by
China from the United States year after
year for decades will and must stop our
great American companies are hereby
ordered to immediately start looking for
an alternative to China including
bringing your companies home and making
your products in the USA I'll be
responding to China's tariffs this
afternoon because China levied some
tariffs on the United States he says
this is a great opportunity for the
United States also I'm ordering all
carriers including FedEx Amazon ups in
the post office to search for and refuse
all deliveries of fentanyl from China or
anywhere else fencin all kills 100,000
Americans per year president G said this
would stop it didn't our economy because
of our gains in the last two-and-a-half
years is much larger than that of China
we'll keep it that way okay again this
is mixed signals are you are you opposed
to China because of their international
their international activity or are you
opposed to China because you have a
weird view on trade that is not
economically correct spell out mr.
president to the American people spell
out to the American people why this
needs to be done why we need this war
why would it not not in over war nobody
wants in over war with China why we need
to fight an economic war with China and
it can't just be they stole our
intellectual property we've got a World
Trade Organization that we can sue them
for for that it needs to be what their
international ambitions are and why we
have to stand tall against those
international ambitions and again Trump
keeps coming back to this idea that
they've been cheating us on trade okay
cheating us on International Property
correct cheating us on trade not so much
he says our country's been losing
hundreds of billions of dollars a year
to China with no end in sight here's the
thing if you could substitute Mexico for
China it's not a good argument hey the
reason that we should be opposed to what
the Chinese government is doing is not
merely because they've stolen our
intellectual property although that's a
pretty good reason we should be opposed
to what the Chinese government is doing
because socialism is evil a social
centralized government nationalised
government is evil it has proved itself
so over the last century and a half but
Trump is focusing on the economics of
this in a sort of Peter in a viral way
and that is not economically accurate
and he's heading up from political
perspective he's setting up expectations
he won't be able to fulfill if he makes
this
all about how breaking up with China is
going to benefit the American economy no
such luck
hey you are asking the American people
to undertake a sacrifice and during
World War two FDR was not shy about
explaining to the American people the
sacrifices they would have to undertake
during the Cold War JFK was not shy
about asking the American people what
sacrifices they would have to undertake
Trump should not be shy about telling
the American people the threat of China
and explaining the threat of China
because China is in fact a threat
China's a threat and pretending that
China's not a threat is a mistake and by
the way this would be a good good great
opportunity to explain the differences
between the American system and the
Chinese system instead here's the way
this looks like this is gonna go look it
does not look as though the Trump
administration is going to take a
hard-line position on China for the
foreseeable future
simply because if Trump is unwilling to
explain why Americans should sacrifice
to fight Chinese influence around the
globe like Hong Kong why isn't Trump on
TV every night talking about Hong Kong
would this be a perfect example of
Chinese violation of treaties I mean
they literally signed a treaty with the
British in 97 when the British abdicated
in Hong Kong that they would not violate
the human rights of the people of Hong
Kong they proceeded to do exactly that
okay why wouldn't I mean Trump is doing
a lot of the right things but he's not
talking about it right he's actually
providing the weaponry Taiwan needs to
defend itself against Chinese aggression
but then he won't talk about it
why won't we just talk about this if
he's talking about North Korea as a
world threat he used to talk about China
placing pressure on the North Koreans
well the fact is if we're gonna face
down the Chinese there will be
sacrifices that are necessary but I
think the most likely scenario here is
that the Chinese forced trump back to
the table not because Trump is likely to
want to come back to the table but
because if he does not then the economy
is likely going to sink further as we
approach the election she knows this and
so she could easily tank the United
States economy simply by selling the
trillions of dollars in US bonds the
Chinese government owes on the open
market doing so would completely
undercut the demand for US bonds make it
very difficult for us to sell our debt
send those interest rates back up if
President Trump claimed on Monday that
Chinese officials are now prepared to
return to the negotiating table
this is
most likely scenario signaling there may
be a path to a potential date on sand
his tit-for-tat trade war with Beijing
Trump told reporters China called last
night our top trade people and said
let's get back to the table they've been
hurt very badly but they understand this
is the right thing to do and I have
great respect for it they want to make a
deal and that's a great thing the
Chinese foreign ministry however is
undercutting that he spokesperson Gang
Shuang Shuang appeared to dispute the
president's claim he said I haven't
heard about this apparently the Treasury
secretary Steve minuchin told reporters
that Chinese Vice Premier Li oh he had
called for talks to resume when Trump
pressed him for details during a
bilateral meeting later in the afternoon
with the Indian Prime Minister was not
immediately clear if minuchin was
referring to a phone call you made to
the US officials or his comments at a
technology conference earlier that day
my Trump is taking the position that the
tariffs are helping the American economy
they are not of course because tariffs
don't generally help any economy
including the economy to lovey's
botero´s he again I think that the
leverage right now because Trump has not
made the case to the American people is
on the side of the Chinese also because
again she doesn't have to worry about
his own people if they fuss with him and
he simply imprisons them so that means
that the Chinese have the leverage
unless Trump makes the case so mr.
president make the case get out there
explain to the American people why
you're doing what you were doing and it
is not just because trade wars are good
and easy to win because that is not true
but China is in it is an imperturbable
foe an imperturbable foe they cannot be
perturbed they are a foe with a long
vision they're playing a long game
they're expanding their reach not just
in their immediate region but in outside
regions as well they're forming
alliances with America's enemies there
they're forming alliances with the
Iranians and with the Russians the
president has a strong case against
China it's time for him to prosecute it
ok time first and things I like and then
some things that I hate so things that I
like today so my yesterday was a bad day
we want to go to Disneyland there was
kind of a screw-up at Disneyland and so
I couldn't take my kids which was too
bad but we decided instead that we would
take them to their first in theater
movie which is always a risky
proposition because I have a five year
old in a three year old she is fully
capable of sitting through a movie in a
theater my son not too much he's up and
down he's bouncing around but we
it's a toy story for and it's pretty
great okay the the Toy Story series I
have to admit when I saw the first Toy
Story I was not a huge fan
Toy Story 2 is fantastic Toy Story 3 is
similarly fantastic Toy Story 4 is
probably not as good as 2 or 3 but it's
still very very good here's a little bit
of preview
every one body made a friend in class
no no she literally made a new friend I
want you to meet four key
he's a spool yes yeah I know four key is
the most important toy to Bonnie right
now we all have to make sure nothing
happened one of the things that's that
Pixar has done so well over the years of
course is they've they've really placed
adult messages in children's films this
this movie is basically about baby
boomers retiring is what the movie is
about and deciding to get out there and
have fun with your life and not dwell on
the past that's really what this movie
is about what's hilarious what's what's
interesting about the Toy Story series
it starts off as a series about children
in childhood and then it moves through
adolescence and then it moves to
adulthood and now it's moving to
retirement it sort of dealt with death
last time around in Toy Story 3 the
movie is entertaining it's very good
Tony Hale who plays for ki is kind of
fantastic my kids loved it and again one
of the great things about Pixar is that
you can really enjoy the film as an
adult even as your kids are laughing at
it while they completely missed the the
deeper messages of the film so you can
go check out Toy Story 4 totally worth
the watch ok time for a quick thing that
I hate all righty so Andrew Luck is this
terrific quarterback of the Indianapolis
Colts or should I say ex quarterback of
the Indianapolis Colts he won Comeback
Player of the Year last year he was seen
as sort of the the great hope to replace
Peyton Manning in Indianapolis and he
was great I mean last year he threw for
39 touchdowns he was excellent well he
decided that he was going to retire from
the NFL he was 29 years old and he
decided he was going to retire because
he just keeps getting injured he doesn't
want to be battered and bruised and
ruined anymore he's sick of it he did a
postgame press conference in which he
explained that the injuries he's
undergone have taken too big a toll on
his psyche
felt stuck and the only way out of it is
to no longer play football it's taken my
joy away from the game
people were enraged at him how dare he
and so as he made his way off the field
following a 27 to 17 pregame loss fans
at Lucas Oil Stadium started to boo him
and fans were very upset with him hey
it's his body it's his life
frankly good good for him good for him
okay the in in seven seasons with the
team he led them to the playoffs four
times in the three years he didn't it
was because he missed games due to
injury you know the fact that he was
booed off the field i I understand as a
fan being upset that the the quarterback
on whom your team had staked its future
is his leaving but the fact is he's
gonna have to live with his body for the
next 60 years and you or not and and
good for him good for him I really have
serious doubts frankly about the future
viability of the NFL simply because it's
an inherently dangerous sport the the
NFL continues to market itself is a not
dangerous sport it is clearly a
dangerous sport there's something to be
said for the idea that the NFL really
should have taken a different tack on
all of this which is yes we're a
dangerous sport get over it that's the
tack that UFC has taken yeah you're
gonna see people beat the crap out of
each other and it's not safe and people
are gonna get hurt and that's the way it
is but because the NFL wants to be a
youth sport and a mainstream sport and
not sort of an underground violent sport
because of that they have moved into
this weird area where they proclaim that
they are safe while they are not in fact
safe
well the retirement of Andrew Luck is
going to be another blow to that sort of
press for the NFL but frankly good for
Andrew Luck I hope he lives a happier
healthier life because he's made this
decision he doesn't know anything to the
fans he is a man doing a job and if he
decides to no longer do the job that is
not his obligation and if fans don't
like it well frankly they can stick it
because they're not the ones we're gonna
have to live with concussions and broken
ankles and inability to walk around
without paying the next morning I say
that as a big sports fan alrighty we'll
be back here later today with a couple
more additional hours of content I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily weiter
2019 if you want to delve the depths of
leftist madness head on over to the
Michael Noel's show where we examine
what's really going on beneath the
surface of our politics and bask in the
simple joys of being right
[Music]